congratulations Stephanie crash was my
sister stephanie has worked for the
United Nation 4 I don't know the past
decade I want to say and she's always
been out of the country and she goes to
dangerous places mostly in Africa she
got big danger pay all of this crazy
stuff freaking out my parents yeah ey
yeah yeah and she she was longing to
come home and she she came back and she
was applying for a job and she got two
jobs looking for so exciting that I'm
here in Seattle with Jen hey guy from
you so much and I said congrats we
should go out and she said have a drink
in Seattle for me so here we are having
a drink for you Stephanie Stahl rate I
like it though that such an found a good
sign yeah there you go and gents theme
this month is celebration celebration
exactly yeah celebrating the RZA silver
and think to your life so it's the
perfect way to celebrate I love it and
then so those are you watching my
sister's name is Stephanie with an F ste
f anie I guess it'll be entitled video
so give her congratulations leave in the
comments below I'm gonna have her watch
all your comments a booster on she's
back in Tron are all excited thank you
guys for watching to believe these death
of a congrats we'll see you soon